do you want to stay on Kyla and talk to
fight a bit we didn't even talk about
the fight Steve stay for a little bit
yeah well I only saw the main I only saw
the khabib and we saw the cabbie born in
the Holly home that's all we gonna talk
okay so MMA admit it
where's Steve and Kyle yeah Steve your
thoughts on the hubby UFC 219 huh
I was practically blown away I didn't
okay I knew he was good right he's a
good recipe now for a while but yeah you
know I didn't think he was that good and
my brother remind me this [ __ ]
used to wrestle dope grizzly bears when
he was like nine yeah but what he did to
Barbosa is the complete control and the
the even the under hooks and like I even
watched post fight analysis and the
stuff he was doing that there's details
he was doing I didn't realize while I
was watching it and the guy brought it
up to like Rogen and in Dominic weren't
even talking about he would grapevine
his leg he would intertwine his leg a
figure for his leg so he couldn't even
trap him yeah he would trap his leg like
grape on it and then he was doing
intricate stuff like he would grab his
wrist here just with the neck it's just
like the complete domination and control
within the Octagon he was closing the
distance he was just like a leech on him
the whole gets Barbosa is not a chump by
any means no he has one of the hardest
kicks I have ever seen like his entire
highlight reel is just like chaos from
kicks yeah
even while he was being wobbled he was
still throwing kicks still get knocked
yeah he was a wobbly like but he really
just I mean that was I mean you heard
the score right he was like what 30 25
30 24 30 25 he [ __ ] he was he drowned
him he was drowning him like in deep
water if he fought Connor and Connor was
on the guy with him it's over well I
think that would be so cool to watch and
I that would be a dream fight him or
Tony Ferguson even like if max Holloway
stepped up or you know I won't want to
see any of those because they would be
you know they could go the distance but
I think Abby is I think he's no one
wants to fight him yeah people been
dunking that guy for years and
I could see why now I just wanted to
stay healthy hook hubby I didn't know he
had a nutritionist yeah but he has been
injured like several times you know
that's what this whole night sliders are
waiting for him to get injured during
like training or something it's like
they don't want to find out him busy
train with aka wood core me right yeah
not there all the time his home country
but I think that he has an edge he has a
mental edge he has a dog astonied yeah
it's like he was raised he didn't have
it like an easy life yeah and I wrestled
so his type of wrestling is different
too because I'm like he's not even
shooting i crotches doubles or singles
even the MMA kind yeah this guy's got
more I don't even know it's like a
fusion of like a greco-roman yeah judo
controlling thing that he does where he
has complete control of your cuz he was
taken down like not even shooting yeah
he had like a under hook under barbosa's
left yeah arm and he was anchoring and
he's maybe though in wrestling you could
ankle pick maybe yeah but here he would
literally I don't even know how he took
him down he was just complete
greco-roman yeah brute strength
positioning it's weird it's like his own
type it's his own wrestling that's why
I'm so like like really shocked by his
skill level he's so marketable so many
people love him he's got like 1 million
followers he is an international
sensation yeah everyone roots for him
there's something about him that we just
all really want to you know keep our
eyes peeled for yeah who could beat that
guy I mean I'm trying to think I don't
maybe Ferguson if he goes off far that's
very creative with his jujitsu I will I
feel like on the ground it's you can be
interesting with those two yes Habib is
not so much a jujitsu guys but I think
he's I also think that his IQ on the
ground is so like he's inherently good I
don't think that maybe he has the same
like jujitsu training but I think that
he knows his body body positioning yeah
so well control yeah it's all about
control he's he's a damn good rest on
Pierce though how he would do on his
back so here wrestlers don't like be on
their back and then further that's true
love's be on his back well or on top
well what would happen to Habibi fuse on
his back I don't know but that saying I
don't know this beards I don't know
how well-versed years in that I love him
but that would be something fun to watch
man Tony Ferguson and then the main
event Cris cyborg and Holly Holm I give
mad props to Holly for standing five
rounds against somebody that dominant
yeah cuz I don't think anyone's lasted
that long against Chris tyberg
she had good combos she had a good game
plan the first change it and she kept
doing the same thing figured it out yeah
yeah maybe the first two rounds I felt
like cyborg was a little frustrating oh
yeah because Holly remind me of the
Ronda Rousey fight I wish a moving and
dipping in and out of her punches but
good feet yeah but I noticed though even
after the bell she did some sucker
punches after the bell rang yeah she got
some good hits on her dude two rounds
cyborg the last 30 seconds when she
would activate and turn it on because I
think that she was trying to be
economical with her a gas tank yeah
because I think a lot of people do
wonder when girls are that bigger anyone
fighters that big like how long they can
actually last in the ring or in the
Octagon but she was so in shape and she
she didn't gas out at all Frank was
still there but I also think that
usually she comes out like in with a
flurry and she just knocks girls out in
the first round it's over right Tonya
avenger' kind of last Holly was moving
around too well though she was majalis
amazing I felt like her punches just
didn't have the same power obviously to
like cyborgs way more power yeah that's
that's but that's cyborg it's like if if
any of her punches land she's already
you know she's dampening your [ __ ] so
she's not she's not no steroids right in
her past
the random e who who was the initial 145
champion vacated the the title because
she said she didn't want to fight cyborg
because cyborg had cyborg had been
previously tagged for using for being on
the gear cuz it's obviously her voices
right although I don't know how she can
get away with it now like I'm I don't
know what goes inside like you know
fighters in between like fight camps and
stuff but it's really hard with asada
because the slaughter really does then
what I know they do you know yeah the
testing is yeah yeah you're right out of
camp during camp
anytime it's like they're subject to
being tested you know so she has in the
past so she has okay that's all I'm
asking yeah yeah
so it's audible system basically every
single MMA fighters on has been well
Coco saying - yeah Coco saying your
heroes have all been on it yeah except
maybe I don't think the Diaz brothers
aren't the Diaz brothers don't do that I
probably might smoke a little weed but
that's about it yeah I don't think
Michael Bisping ever I know for some
reason I never think Mark Hunt ever did
either he didn't probably let's not get
ourselves on backstage the tournaments
yeah they're doing something to stay
alive for five yeah but you can't you
can't ride backstage and then perform
like Roy ting happens like over time the
strength that you get from them they're
also not smart so they're all probably
just doing [ __ ] in the back that they
think gives him that what was the one
that John Jones was in was on where in
fact it was like a some kind of black
market thing yeah I think it was like
some kind of protein or like a lifting
weight pill or something that had that
element I don't know it is an anabolic
there was a quest part I'm looking for
what's the heavyweight bout coming up Bo
chick and I know that's good do you have
your money on I don't know I just want
to see it can I say something that's
very controversial I know like Francis
Mangano is good everyone is like on that
I've steep it I do too I feel it yeah
cuz in Ghana hasn't been tested we don't
know what he's like I guess what I mean
what Alastor over him is a great test
though it's whoever lands first or
whoever wins so it's not like the lower
weights where you can kind of go back
and forth a little bit like with these
heavyweights there [ __ ] they have so
much power behind their punches because
they have all that weight in it that
really it's whoever lands first but it's
like if steep a I feel like watching
previous the god who's previous fights
he'll probably take a different approach
to try like take him down yeah I think I
was trying to keep him on the cage he
didn't have a chance to actually take
down no and he pays a good wrestler
and I also want to see if this I don't
know if they'll happen but Dillashaw
Mighty Mouse if he cuts down that's the
other if I I would like to see and then
max Holloway all of his fights because
he's [ __ ] on
like all right guys
[Music]